qué balance se puede hacer de este
periodo de boluarte en el poder
creo que lo que marca este periodo es En
definitiva la fuerte represión de la
movilización social y la falta de
escucha tanto por parte del gobierno
como por parte del parlamento que está
respaldando el gobierno en el pedido de
buena parte de la población las
encuestas nos hablan de hasta 80% del
pedido del que haya un adelanto de
elecciones lo antes posible bueno hay
una amplia condena al gobierno de la
mandataria Cómo se ve su panorama y que
viene para el ejecutivo
Ay efectivamente en el en el panorama
inmediato un incremento de las
movilizaciones que se detuvieron durante
el mes de febrero en varias regiones
producto de las festividades que suelen
darse pero que ya están anunciadas en la
ciudad de hecho desde la región de puno
de la población la población aymara se
está movilizando hacia la capital y eso
va a recrudecer la mandataria va a tener
que demostrar que realmente está
dispuesta a escuchar o si va a seguir
optando por la represión como hemos
visto y como hemos visto incluso este
fin de semana nuevamente con lo cual
parece difícil que lleguemos a algún
nivel de paz o tranquilidad sino que nos
mantendremos en un conflicto social
fuerte bueno ya hablemos de Pedro
Castillo cómo va su proceso
su proceso está aún en la primera parte
declaraciones este fin de semana además
se encontraron algunos videos se
hicieron públicos videos en los cuales
se ve como él dirigió efectivamente la
operación del mensaje a la nación por el
cual intentaba dar un autogolpe No él
había tratado de indicar que esto había
sido un poco forzado y las imágenes
demostraron que no era así que junto con
su primer ministra y su asesor y ex
Primer Ministro habían decidido este de
golpe con lo cual es muy improbable que
él pueda salir y más bien en los
próximos días deberían definirse los 36
meses de prisión preventiva que se están
pidiendo para él por los casos de
corrupción y por el tema del autogolpe
también